larry what are your thoughts on the
antonio brown uh
situation one of your
fellow
your fellow wide receivers who
approaches things somewhat differently
than yourself
and i love abe he's mr big chest is a
good friend of mine
um but i don't think he's going about it
the right way personally um
you know to be able to play with a
all-time quarterback like he's able to
play with i don't think he understands
how good he has it you know it's
it could it could be
it could get tough out there it could
get tough out there
[Applause]
[Music]
wow larry fitzgerald saying what needs
to be said about antonio brown and when
you look at the list of quarterbacks
that larry fitzgerald has had to endure
over the course of his career now a
couple of great ones in kurt warner and
carson palmer but the rest not nearly as
great all due respect to our friend sean
king he was one of those guys but plenty
of quarterbacks for larry fitzgerald not
nearly as many for antonio brown there
have been games that ben rothersburg has
missed due to injury but rothersburg has
been the guy antonio brown may want to
be careful what he wishes for because
the teams that have surfaced espn
reported on friday night oakland
tennessee
and washington the three suitors for
brown good luck finding a guy anywhere
close to roethlisberger in those three
cities yeah exactly right i mean first
of all there's so much to talk about i
know we've talked about this a lot last
week but antonio brown well larry
fitzgerald let's just jump off right
there i mean first of all yeah he
larry fitzgerald would not go about this
situation the way antonio brown is
certainly you know again with antonio
brown being on lebron james show on hbo
uh you know what what is it what is it
called the the show by i'm blanking the
shop the shop exactly right where you
know he starts going in on big ben and
some of the situations that you know led
to the demise of the relationship
between him and the pittsburgh steelers
you know and i understand his
frustrations i mean the point he made
about hey big ben roethlisberger threw
an interception into a defensive lineman
in the denver game and he blamed antonio
brown that was wrong that was crappy you
know i i don't agree with everything
bing ben roethlisberger does we we know
that he's got some issues too with the
way he leads but at the same time
antonio brown is only hurting himself
with the way he's talking about this
situation you and i know so many coaches
and gm's around the nfl and
players that act this way does not make
those guys those coaches and gm's we
talk about feel comfortable about
bringing in some supposed renegade into
the organization where you don't know
when he's gonna spout off or be unhappy
and based on some of the things he's
been saying recently now he's been on
his best behavior chris on social media
since he had his meeting with art rooney
the second nearly two weeks ago but the
comments to the shop and those were
taped a couple of weeks ago in
connection with the nba all-star game
festivities in charlotte but the more
recent interview with jeff darlington of
espn
the things he's saying i don't need
football and if they're going to play
they're going to play by my rules that
does not make a team anxious to give up
significant draft pick compensation to
the steelers the steelers reportedly
want a first round pick i don't know
that they're going to get one but the
one thing that became clear to me last
night because i got my hands on antonio
brown's contract and the first look at
it resulted in a conclusion that even if
the steelers keep him beyond march 17
there's a good chance that the next team
would actually pay that two and a half
million dollar roster bonus because the
money gets paid out not in march but
during the season so you could say hey
new team you're taking this guy on
you're paying the money the steelers
don't want to take that extra two and a
half million dollar cap charge i already
taken 21.12
you throw another two and a half on top
of it they're trying to avoid in fact
i'm told the steelers asked brown to
delay the due date of that roster bonus
to give them more time to trade him and
he said no so there really is a sense
that the deal is going to get done
before that roster bonus becomes due and
and you know we've been saying well
you've got to make the steelers happy
and you've got to give brown a new
contract it's possible that they could
do this trade without brown getting his
contract right out of the gates that
that would be something that comes later
with both sides taking a leap of faith
that they would work out a new deal at
some point down the road that makes it
easier to get this done by march 17 if
it's just the steelers and
getting what they want and brown being
comfortable with the team he's going to
well mike i i saw you wrote so you don't
think pittsburgh can pay him that bonus
as far as when the season starts uh with
can they spread it out then and then if
they were to yeah that's
yes go ahead that's how it's written
right that's how it's written the
contract is written that the two and a
half million dollars is earned on i
technically if he's still on the roster
after the close of business on march 16
that money is earned right but it's paid
out in weekly installments along with
his salary during the season so the
steelers could in theory trade him after
march 17 and say to the new team you're
paying the two and a half million not us
that could happen right but the concern
for the steelers is they don't want to
take the extra cap hit yeah because as
of march 17 his cap number goes up by
another two and a half million and it's
part of what they're gonna have to carry
and what they're gonna have to deal with
that's why they've asked him to bump
that back just the mere fact that they
asked him to bump it back it tells me
they're viewing that as the trigger for
trading him and i know we've got what do
we got we got dinner and darby's on this
exactly where where
and let's make sure we're clear yes if
if he's traded
by
the the march 17 due date of the roster
bonus i win right if they keep him after
that you win yeah is that right exactly
right i can't wait i like you know
medium well stake uh i'm very fine
establishment i want a side of fries
maybe some adult beverages to go along
with it so yeah a couple of 1942 there's
like five or six seven exactly that's
right 1942 is nice and expensive so it
really hurts your american express card
but uh i mean i'm right there you know
listen i i think the thing with antonio
brown there or the pittsburgh steelers i
should say in this whole situation is
they can't be afraid to have to be on
the hook for this two and a half million
dollars either i mean if they're not
getting the the compensation or having
the conversations with some of the teams
around the nfl and don't feel like
they're going to get the value that's uh
just for their team and their
organization then hey they got to be
tough here in this one this is not going
to be easy but regardless this is
antonio brown he's one of the best
receivers in football he's acted like a
renegade he's disrespected your
franchise and i know there's maybe other
people like a big ben who have
disrespected him to a degree as well but
you can't start the president precedence
of oh we're gonna let our players call
the shots around here and and when
they're unhappy they can start not
showing up for practice or being late
for meetings and then oh yeah the
squeaky wheel always gets the oil around
here they can't let that happen either
so they're gonna have to drive a hard
bargain and this might get ugly but
pittsburgh's got to be prepared to to
take that on
well and that's what they have at their
disposal and i don't think that antonio
brown aka mr big chess realizes what
he's potentially walking into if the
steelers say
sorry antonio we couldn't find an
acceptable trade off or we're going to
keep you because they could for example
if he decides he's going to skip out on
practice he's going to show up late he's
going to break the rules they could get
tough with him and they could suspend
him for conduct detrimental to the team
and they could attack his signing bonus
they could attack that roster bonus that
roster bonus isn't fully guaranteed when
he earns it he could lose that if he
commits breaches of his contract within
the confines of of the the different
things in the labor deal that could
cause that money to be lost and if he
ultimately says i don't need football
i'm retired find antonio brown but
you're gonna have to cough up 11.4
million dollars back to the steelers
that you've already received in signing
bonus money that you've yet to earn and
i just wonder whether he understands
that chris you know we understand it
because we've been around it but i think
some of these younger guys who haven't
had to deal with these issues they think
signing bonuses free money they think
they won the lottery no it is advanced
compensation right for services to be
rendered and it's 11.4 million as of
right now that he has not earned that if
he would retire from the steelers if
they can't trade him and he says i'm
done he's going to have to come up with
that money yeah exactly right i mean
they at the end of the day have a lot of
power in this situation yeah antonio
brown can make it ugly and make it real
uncomfortable for them and maybe try to
act you know even more renegade-ish to
where it devalues his trade value but if
he'd better he better watch out for that
altogether it might just piss pittsburgh
off and they might just go the hell with
it fine you want to like keep talking
trash here then we'll slow play this and
take all day and really wait to what we
get to till we get an offer that we
really like the big number in this too
this
forget the two and a half million on
march 17th the steelers are on the hook
for 21 million dollars with antonio
brown this year no matter what even when
they trade him so that is the big number
i look at to where they can't let uh 23
and a half scare them off their mark as
compared to 21 when it comes to that
march 17th payment uh they they have
invested a lot in antonio brown they
have dealt with his shenanigans and all
the things that have come along with him
and like i said to start they can't let
guys start holding the team hostage and
calling the shots around there
yeah i agree with you completely and if
if they have
decided that this guy is someone that
they want to be done with then so be it
take the best offer you can and move on
but if they really do have a hard floor
on what they want for antonio brown and
they don't get it i think it makes more
sense for them to dig in and play
hardball with antonio brown because if
they don't now there's going to be
another antonio brown coming down the
pike that tries to do things the exact
same way exactly that antonio brown is
doing that right then again you could
say i already have a guy like that his
name's ben roethlisberger well yeah but
that's a different discussion all
together yeah we're going to take a very
quick return go ahead go ahead i'm going
to say well even you know hey big ben he
might be a pain in the butt and not
always perfect but he's on time for
meetings he's prepared to practice those
things like that too where you know
again those are issues that antonio
brown has had while playing for the
pittsburgh steelers
and let me just add one thing before we
go i still think there's a chance that
the reason brown is saying all these
things is that he knows that
roethlisberger and i'm not saying this
has happened but i wouldn't rule it out
that roethlisberger's already said to
the team look it's him or me i can't
take this guy anymore one of us is going
and one of us is staying and maybe brown
knows that if that's happened and maybe
that's why brown
comes off as just so defiant and so
confident that they are going to move on
from i mean chris that's a wild card in
all this if if ben has said if this
guy's not gone i'm gone then he is going
to be gone by march 17 when that two and
a half million becomes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports